i don't mean to sound like a scold i  know i do but i i don't mean to i don't  even mean to place myself above the  epidemic levels of narcissism that are  plaguing our culture i'm not above it  we're in it we live at a time that  especially encourages and exacerbates  this culture of narcissism we live in an  increasingly digital world that  insulates us from physical reality it's  no coincidence that most of the most  prominent detransitioners these are the  people who had fallen under the sway of  gender ideology  and saw the light came out on the other  side to reality it's no coincidence that  many of them describe falling into it  through social media social media which  revolve around self-obsession and which  permit an unprecedented degree of self  deception and illusion the social media  platforms that have replaced the town  square are designed to addict you to  likes to the affirmation of others